today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
the president was interviewed by fox
news host chris
wallace in an interview that aired
yesterday and
it is unlike anything that i've ever
seen and i want to spend some time today
looking at it with you and it's really
the stuff of history i mean this is an
interview that needs to be analyzed
really like that infamous as a pruder
film because the english language
is stretched to its limit to even
explain and describe what took place
during this interview donald trump at
one point stopped the interview to try
to get documents
proving joe biden wants to abolish the
police
which joe biden doesn't want to do and
donald trump was
unable to prove with those documents he
tried to get
trump was sweating so badly that at one
point it looked like
flop sweat he was glistening and
dripping with sweat throughout the
interview
trump referred to world wars 1 and 2 as
beautiful beautiful
trump challenged joe biden to a
cognitive test
and accused the interviewer chris
wallace of being unable to answer some
of the test
questions on the cognitive test
and that's like only the half of it
trump has insulted
people in interviews but he was unhinged
here
trump has said dumb and wrong things in
interviews
but trump seemed impaired here so let's
get right out into it uh
sit down join me in this adventure which
is really a horror show
the country can never allow something
like this to happen
again it is historic in its level of
insanity
i'm going to start with arguably one of
the most deranged moments of the entire
thing
which is that chris wallace shows trump
a poll
about trump versus biden on mental
soundness which we'll talk about later
more people in the poll it's a fox news
poll more people think joe biden is
mentally sound
to be president than the number who
think trump is mentally sound
and donald trump starts saying not only
can he do better than biden on a
cognitive test
it gets really ugly and he actually says
to chris wallace
i would do better than you you would
struggle to answer some of the questions
on the cognitive test completely and
utterly unhinged
people who is more competent who's got
whose mind
is sounder biden beats you in that well
i tell you what
uh let's take a test let's take a test
right now
let's go down joe and i will take a test
let him take the same test
that i took incidentally i took the test
too when i heard that you passed it yeah
how did you do
well
that's all misrepresentation that's what
it was on the web it's all
misrepresentation
because yes the first few questions are
easy but i'll bet you couldn't even
answer the last five questions i'll bet
you couldn't they get very hard the last
five well one of them was count back
from 100 by seven
and let me tell you if you couldn't
answer
you couldn't answer all right what's the
question many of the questions i'd get
you the test i'd like to give it
but i guarantee you that joe biden could
not answer those questions
okay and i answered all 35 questions
correctly
we're clearly desensitized by more than
three years
of this because the president of the
united states told
the interviewer that the interviewer
would be unable to do as well on a
cognitive test meant to screen out
dementia
than the way trump answered the
questions and it's like just a blip
honestly there were equally crazy things
in this interview never mind other
things that happened this weekend
there are some real questions here
though that that i should mention
what test is trump talking about because
trump talks about the 35 questions the
montreal cognitive assessment which is
as far as we know what trump took
and it was certainly what chris wallace
was referring to it doesn't have 35
questions it's based
out of 30 points but we don't actually
know what test trump is referring to
trump not may not even remember the test
itself and as far as we knew trump took
that test a year or two ago
but trump recently said i just took it
when was that and where we're not aware
of trump being administered that or any
other cognitive test
recently this was maybe the most
mind-numbingly
bizarre moment of the interview then we
get on to
the biden attacks here trump says biden
wants to defund the police
joe biden doesn't want to defund or
abolish the police
and in fact there's people on the left
who are mad at joe biden because he
doesn't want to defund or abolish the
police
and chris wallace calls trump on it
trump stops the interview
to try to get the proof that that's what
biden wants to do
of course it doesn't work that way
because biden doesn't want to abolish
the police take a look
you've seen deaths up in
new york deaths up in chicago shootings
how do you explain it and what are you
going to do about it i explained it very
simply by saying that the democrat-run
cities they're
liberally run they're stupidly run
liberal
democrats have been running cities in
this country for decades poorly
why is it so bad right now they've run
them poorly it was always bad but now
it's gotten
totally out of control and it's really
because they wanted to fund the police
and biden wants to fund the funding
sir he does not look he signed a
charter with bernie sanders he says
nothing about defunding
oh really it says abolish it says let's
go
all right give me the charter please all
right
so that led to a very interesting
exchange where he had his staff go out
and get
the highlights from that hundred page
compact that the biden team
and the trump team uh rather the biden
team and the sanders team had signed
and he went through it and he found a
lot of things that he objected to that
biden has agreed to
but he couldn't find any indication
because there isn't any
that joe biden has uh sought to defund
and abolish the police
just amazing i mean lots of people wish
biden wanted to defund the police or
abolish the police
but he doesn't want to and chris wallace
fact-checking trump in real time there
now in a moment i'm going to get to
chris wallace more more deeply
but for now wallace is at least doing
the the basic
fact checking now you'd think that after
that bogus attack on biden completely
backfired
trump wouldn't try another one but he
tries to suggest
biden will end religion in the united
states if joe biden is president
according to trump joe biden will end
religion take a look and we'll call
religion will be gone
okay life you could forget about that
the whole question of life
support when you say life you mean
abortion absolutely
a hundred percent that whole question
which is a very you know it's always
been a 50 50
thing it's actually trending a little
bit more toward
when i say religion is going to be gone
what does that mean look at what they're
doing to the churches
they won't let the churches even open if
they want to stand in a field
six feet apart now i've said before i
don't care if a president is religious
i just want religion kept out of
governance that's secularism secular
secularism isn't people can't be
religious it's
in their role as as a public servant
religion should play no
role in that governance but the facts
happen to be joe biden's more religious
than donald trump i mean
it's not a preference i don't care about
presidential religiosity
but we know trump is not religious and
only pretends to be religious in order
to appeal to evangelical voters
trump might even be an atheist i have a
segment about this that i did
a couple years ago joe biden is a
religious guy
and obviously religion will not be gone
under joe biden
just bungled bizarre claim after claim
here by donald trump
at another point in the interview trump
refers to world war one and world war ii
as beautiful wars apropos of nothing i
mean this was
sort of like related to confederate
statues and monuments and he throws in
that that the wars were beautiful
and he also says what are you gonna name
stuff after all al sharpton or something
the national defense authorization act
the ndaa you have threatened to veto
it because in the bill and this is
supported by republicans as well as
democrats it would rename
army bases named for confederate
generals now this is a bill that
funds military operations it gives
soldiers a pay raise
you're going to veto that because
they'll get their pay raise hey look
don't tell me this
i got soldiers the biggest pay raises in
the history of our understood
of our military i got soldiers brand new
equipment brand new jets brand new
rockets brand new 2.5 trillion i did
more for the military
than any president that's ever had this
is going to be
because i think that fort bragg fought
robert and lee all of these forts that
have been named that way for
a long time decades and decades the
military says therefore
excuse me i don't care what the military
says i do
i'm supposed to make the decision fort
bragg is a big deal
we won two world wars nobody even knows
general bragg
we won two world wars go to that
community where fort bragg is in a great
state i love that state
go to go to the community say how do you
like the idea of
renaming fort bragg and then what are we
going to name it
you're going to name it after the
reverend al sharpton what are you going
to name it chris
tell me what you're going to name it
this is the interview version
of a sort of a rorschach test it's like
an ink blot what do you see here it's
complete free association
and in terms of november chris wallace
gives donald trump the results of a new
fox news poll in which biden is plus
eight we're going to look at that poll
in detail later and trump just says oh
it's all fake polling
mr president you'll be happy to know
that fox news has a new poll
out today and you're going to be the
very first person to hear about it
in the national horse race joe biden
leads you by eight points
49 to 41 that's i think three four
points slimmer
than it was a month ago and on the
issues people
trust biden more to handle the
coronavirus by 17 points on race
relations by 21 points
and even on the economy they trust biden
moore by one point
i understand we still have more than a
hundred days to this election but at
this point
you're losing first of all i'm not
losing
because those are fake polls they were
fake in 2016
and now they're even more fake the polls
were much worse in 2016.
they interviewed 22 percent republican
well how do you do 22
republican you see what's going on uh i
have other polls that put me
leading and we have polls where i'm
leading i have a poll where we're
leading in every swing state
maybe i don't understand the trumpist
mentality
but it seems to me trump could be
prepared to answer these questions about
polls in a more reasonable way like
if i were trump and of course i'm not
trump if i was dealing with being down
by double digits in most polls and i'm
confronted about it i don't say the
polls are fake i would say
listen chris there's a reality right now
the country's in a tough place because
of coronavirus
and as president the buck stops with me
this is me pretending
to be trump but but reasonable i
understand
the frustration i hear the frustration
my promise to you and to the american
people is
that between now and election day i will
do everything in my power to singularly
focus
on the virus because dealing with the
virus will help the economy it will help
education it will help everything what
matters is polling in november
and i am going to leave no doubt in
every american's mind
that between now and november 3rd they
will see that i am pouring my life
into resolving this situation and in the
end they will see that i've earned a
second term
like wouldn't that be more powerful than
the polls are fake and i'm really
winning you can't trust the fake news
media
on the same topic trump asked was asked
whether he would accept the results of
the upcoming election
trump of course is losing in every poll
but things can change between now and
november
and trump is unwilling to say i will
accept the results
and he says mail in voting could
actually rig the election
you don't know until you see it depends
i think mail-in
voting is is going to rig the election i
really do uh
are you suggesting that you might not
accept the results of the election i
have to say look
hillary clinton asked me the same thing
no i asked you the same thing in the
debate
there is a tradition in this country in
fact one of the prize of this country
is the peaceful transition of power and
that no matter how hard fought a
campaign
is that at the end of the campaign that
the loser concedes to the winner not
saying that you're necessarily going to
be the loser or the winner but that the
loser concedes to the winner
and that the country comes together in
part for the good of the country
are you saying you're not prepared now
that i will tell you at the time i'll
keep you in suspense
well chris and you know what she's the
one
that never accepted it right she never
accepted her loss and she looks like can
you give
can you give a direct answer you will
accept the election
look you i have to see no i'm not going
to just say yes i'm not going to say no
and i didn't last time either remember
that trump doesn't realize
that when we talk about vote by mail
this year
all we're talking about is expanding
absentee ballots for anybody
if they want an absentee ballot they can
they can request one and get one
but trump seems to not understand that
and continues to
refuse to say i will accept the election
results
then we get into coronavirus stuff trump
wrongly claims
that we have one of the lowest mortality
rates in the world that's not true
as i've shown you before our deaths per
capita are the 10th highest in the world
chris wallace calls trump on it and the
white house tried giving chris a
completely bogus chart you're going to
have to take a look at this more closely
and we will talk about it after this
did the european union very early but
when you talk about mortality rates
i think it's the opposite i think we
have one of the lowest mortality rates
kaylie's right here i heard we have one
of the lowest maybe the lowest mortality
rate anywhere in the world
you have the numbers please because i
heard we had the best mortality right
and this is number number one little
mortality right
i hope you show the scenario because it
shows what fake news is all about okay
okay i don't think i'm fake news but
i will we'll put it up we'll put our
stats you said we had the worst
mortality rate in the world
we have the best all right it's a little
complicated but bear with us
we went with numbers from johns hopkins
university which charted the mortality
rate for 20 countries hit by the virus
the u.s ranked seventh better than the
united kingdom
but worse than brazil and russia the
white house went with this chart from
the european cdc
which shows italy and spain doing worse
but countries like brazil
and south korea doing better so what's
interesting about this
is do you believe trump really is being
told we have the lowest mortality rate
like this is a very instructive clip
because our deaths per capita are the
10th highest in the world
what the white house gave fox is a chart
of
case fatality rates which is death
relative to testing which is not
informative here but what's extra wild
about this is
trump has admitted he wanted to slow
down testing to keep case numbers low
the case fatality rate goes up if you
keep case numbers
low so trump's admitted strategy of
trying to slow
testing actually increases the case
fatality rate
which isn't even the right measure so
this is like
incompetence plus ignorance plus
self-inflicted damage
and we're going to compare these metrics
in an upcoming segment because i want to
make sure
that everybody sort of understands all
of the different
components to this now in this next clip
here is
dripping sweaty trump asked about mask
wearing
and he says well you know masks cause
problems too
so definitely no national mask mandate
who
wore a mask for the first time in public
at walter reed
this weekend question the cdc says if
everybody wore
a mask for four to six weeks we could
get this under control
do you regret not wearing a mask in
public from the start
and would you consider will you consider
a national mandate that people need to
wear masks no i want people to have a
certain freedom
and i don't believe in that no and i
don't agree with the statement that if
everybody wear a mask everything
disappears hey dr fauci said don't wear
a mask
our surgeon general terrific guy said
don't wear a mask everybody was saying
don't wear a mask all of a sudden
everybody's got to wear a mess
and as you know mass caused problems too
with that being said
i'm a believer in masks i think masks
are good
bottom line is the president said he is
not going to issue a national mandate on
mass he's going to leave it up to the
individual governors in their states
now what's funny here is trump lists
only reasons not to wear a mask
but says he still supports them like if
he really believed
you know fauci said don't wear one even
though that's been explained
adam said don't wear one the surgeon
general even though that's been
explained
and masks cause problems but i'm still
in favor of them
that's weird in its own way like why
would you be in favor of something
about which you can only name negatives
and and
uh anti-endorsements it doesn't really
make sense
and then we get to sort of this this
kind of bombshell
except it's sort of hard to even believe
chris wallace brings up
since coronavirus hit some people have
lost health insurance
people have lost jobs and their health
insurance is tied to the job so they
lost health insurance
and he mentions fortunately we have the
affordable care act obamacare and people
are signing up for it
but you want to get rid of it why are
you doing this now and trump claims that
in two weeks
there will be a completely brand new
health care system to replace obamacare
what yes take a listen in history
i want to talk about obamacare since the
pandemic hit
millions of people have lost their jobs
and thereby lost their health insurance
and
almost a half a million have signed up
for obamacare your administration just
announced that you're signing on to a
lawsuit
to overturn obamacare and replace it
why does it make sense to overturn
obamacare with which people now are
relying on democrats are going to say
the man who's wanted to kill obamacare
is gonna take away your the protection
for pre-existing conditions first of all
we got rid of the individual mandate
pre-existing conditions will always be
taken care of by me and republicans a
hundred percent but you've been in the
office three and a half years you don't
have to we haven't
excuse me you heard me yesterday we're
signing a health care plan
within two weeks a full and complete
health care plan
that the supreme court decision on daca
gave me the right to do
so we're going to solve we're going to
sign an immigration plan
now this interview was filmed a few days
ago so
it's not two weeks from yesterday
according to when trump said this
he says we are 10 days from a
completely new health care plan what's
the plan
we don't know some republicans must know
about it right somebody must know about
if we're 10 days from a replacement to
obamacare somebody must know about it
we've heard nothing about that at all
from anybody that's been asked
and then here in closing trump attacks
fox news on fox news
this was the start of the interview in
fact which has sort of become a constant
side story trump going after fox news
but chris wallace basically asks if
trump understands journalism
some people were surprised when you
agreed to this interview to sit down
with me
what are you gonna ask especially
because of some of the mean tweets
that you've said about me mike wallace
wanna be nasty
and obnoxious i will tell you after that
one my son peter who you've met called
and he said
nasty no obnoxious maybe
but here's the question one of your beef
seems to be
that i put democrats on the show and i
ask them questions
and i guess the question i have is don't
you understand it's my job
to put democrats on as well as
republicans and to ask them probing
questions just like i ask republicans
i'm not a big fan of fox i'll be honest
with you they've changed a lot since
roger ailes
and i watch people like swalwell who i
don't even know he goes on the show
he got less than one percent so trump
just doesn't
get how journalism works and in fact
there's very little journalism
even happening on fox but the little of
it that is happening
trump hates so i mean what do we make of
this this really is like nothing that
we've ever seen
and my takeaway is anyone supporting
this
is no friend of ours it just can't be
like this has to stop
even if you like low taxes or something
and you consider yourself like a mitt
romney fiscal conservative
you can't support this you you really
can't and this is um
uh uh we we have to be getting to the
end
one quick note about chris wallace chris
wallace has been praised as wow fox news
host obliterate
host obliterates trump and what a great
job he did chris wallace is no great
hero okay
chris wallace is playing softball when
everyone else is playing t-ball
so it looks like he's playing hard
hardball right
in other countries a president this
incompetent wouldn't be able to do a
single interview
because they would all go far worse than
this it would be impossible for
presidents in other countries
based on how media will actually
question presidents remember
trump said during this interview hillary
didn't accept the election results in
2016. what are you talking about
she immediately conceded and we barely
heard from her for a year or longer
trump said biden would turn us into
venezuela
and and chris wallace said nothing now i
understand
you can't i've experienced this you
can't turn every misstatement into a
fight
but the idea that this is some hardball
interview from chris wallace this is
like a five out of ten
and it looks intense because just about
every other interview is a one out of
ten or two out of ten when trump goes on
fox and friends
when trump goes on hannity etc so let's
not give chris wallace more
praise than he deserves although let's
be clear that in in the fox universe
this isn't too common
but remember this plays into fox's
strategy of saying
we have a diversity of views on our
program we have chris wallace
who asks obvious journalistic questions
and then we have everything else who you
know people just gushing
about donald trump don't fall for the
gushing
praise of chris wallace let me know your
reaction to this
i'm on twitter at deepak the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are
christopher david and corey dick
thanks to both of you for signing up at
joinedpakman.com
and also a big thank you to mark henson
for being a member
almost five years mark is today's
longtime sustainer of the day
and you can join them at joinpackman.com
we have a really serious situation of
authoritarianism that ties into
suppression of speech actual suppression
of speech
it possibly ties into the plan to steal
this election in november by donald
trump and what's happening is that
paramilitary
federal law enforcement officers have
been dispatched to portland oregon
they're grabbing people including
protesters not just looters
they're taking them away in unmarked
vehicles they don't have badges
and this has been confirmed by the
department of homeland security this is
really
actually serious these paramilitaries
are driving around
in unmarked cars wearing camouflage
really more appropriate for the desert
than downtown portland oregon
protesters are being detained even in
the absence of evidence that any crime
was committed and this is an
authoritarian
type show of force the claim from the
department of homeland security is that
these troops which really is what they
are
are being sent to portland to keep the
peace and to protect federal property
the stories we're hearing are that
people are being grabbed
thrown in unmarked vans taken to
undisclosed locations not being accused
of any crime in many cases some are
and in most cases they are being
released some
are charged with crimes some of the
people being detained
are not even near federal property which
is supposedly the reason these federal
troops are there in the first place
and many aren't being told why they are
being detained they are just
protesters protected by the first
amendment
the mayor of portland ted wheeler says
he didn't ask for help
he has asked the federal troops to leave
and yet there they are
so that's story number one what is
actually happening
uh on the ground and we're still getting
more information about what's happening
there
the second story is that this is
potentially a test
of what may happen in many cities
starting as soon as this week to repress
protests charlie pierce has a good piece
about this in esquire
where he points out when trump tries
something and gets away with it he does
more of it
and pierce is suggesting maybe this is a
dry run
for what trump was threatening at the
start of the george floyd protests a
couple of months ago
major deployments of militarized law
enforcement or even
straight up military to urban areas so
there's two sub-stories to that second
story
number one is the authoritarianism
spreading to repress protests the second
part is actually
trying to cause confrontations the
troops that is
in order to benefit trump politically by
pointing to violent protesters
which they will induce to violence we've
already seen reports
that the protester protests themselves
are seeing more unrest in portland since
the deployment of the troops so there's
the authoritarianism
but there's also the deployment of
troops to create
unrest to then point to look at all
these violent uh people
we need a bigger show of force which
gets us to the third piece of this
which is these authoritarian forces
being sent into cities now could be a
trial balloon
for sending or keeping them in cities in
november
for the purpose of intimidating around
the election
and that would be like the closure of
the loop in terms of what's going on
that strategy requires some foresight
which trump does not seem able to do
but william barr certainly would be
capable of that and some of the others
involved may well be
now in terms of legality of course
trump's justice department and dhs
say this is legal the aclu and other
lawyers have said
you know th this this could arguably be
kidnapping and abduction right i mean
you've got paramilitaries without badges
and camo
in unmarked cars grabbing people taking
them away
often not telling them what crime
they're suspected of committing and
eventually releasing them without having
charged them of any crime it is going in
the direction of a secret police
sort of thing now to take a brief detour
this is important
as an opportunity to prepare you for
some bad arguments from the right about
this
right-wing darling ben shapiro tweeted
in response to some of what we're seeing
in portland quote
fascism is not federal law enforcement
and forcing the law against rioters and
looters
and they are arresting rioters and
looters in portland not mere protesters
fascism is the chinese government
shuttling uyghurs by train to
concentration camps well
he's right that that certainly uh is
fascistic
what's going on in china and everybody
should be calling it out
and and most people are um but
there's a petri dish of nonsense here
it's almost like a one-sentence gish
gallop because a lot of stuff is being
mixed up
it is true that law enforcement
arresting criminals is not fascism that
that that's completely true
that's not actually what's at issue here
what we have here are
countless videos of mere protesters
being brutally repressed
who have not looted who have not rioted
we have law enforcement in unmarked cars
popping out in a city in camo that does
not match the urban setting in which
they're operating
wearing desert camo without badges that
is deliberate intimidation that's
starting to border on some of the stuff
you see in authoritarian and
totalitarian states and to top it off
there are reports coming in of people
being taken off to undisclosed locations
not being given due process just being
held and ultimately released
so don't fall for law enforcement doing
law enforcement work
isn't fascism no it's not that's not
what this is about
this is about camouflaged military in
unmarked vehicles
sent in to repress protests possibly
as a trial balloon for intimidation to
happen nationally as we approach
election day we almost have a situation
where portland portland police officers
should be protecting protesters
from the guys with no badges in the
unmarked vans
that's how crazy it is don't we have a
right to know who is policing us
aren't combatants as insane as that word
is
required to indicate who they are and
who they work for
anonymous police in camo with no badges
is what's going on right now this could
just as easily be some right wing
militia
as it could be a prison riot squad being
repurposed and in fact
how long will it be until some
right-wing militia that looks just like
these guys
kidnaps and kills someone and it gets
swept under the rug
the city should file a lawsuit and put
it in the hands of the courts
i'd be lying if i said i knew how the
courts would rule
on what's going on this is still
developing we will have more
upcoming okay i want to pick up on this
idea of the us having the lowest
fatality rate when it comes to
coronavirus
donald trump has been saying this a lot
and said it to chris wallace during that
completely
uh gong show fox news interview that we
looked at earlier
and there are different metrics for
different questions
and you are uh i'm not saying you're
being tricked but there are
attempts being made to trick you which
hopefully you aren't
falling for so let's start at the
beginning if we want to know where more
people are dying
you look at the number of deaths right
the problem is
that number would not be adjusted for
the population because different
countries have different populations so
we want to look at per capita if i say
to you a thousand people died of the
virus in the u.s
and a thousand people died in norway
it's a thousand people in both cases but
norway has a smaller population so a
thousand people dying there
is more per capita than in the united
states that's very simple
but i want to go in much more detail and
look at three different metrics and tell
you
where they work and where they don't
work we have deaths per capita
we have the case fatality rate and we
have the infection
fatality rate yesterday donald trump in
his interview with chris wallace said
we have one of the lowest fatality rates
in the world and they put up a graph
that the white house gave fox news and
in this one you have the uk at the top
you have the u.s in the middle and you
have russia sort of closer to the bottom
but if you look at the top of this page
this is the case fatality
rate so the case fatality rate is simply
deaths divided by confirmed cases
so as you can immediately notice the
case fatality rate depends on the number
of tests that you do
if one person dies and 100 people tested
positive that is a case fatality rate of
one percent
one out of a hundred notice that you can
lower your case fatality rate
by doing more tests if one person dies
but i test
a hundred more people meaning now i've
done 200 positive tests
now your case fatality rate is only 0.5
percent
nothing has changed about the portion of
the population that has died
you've just tested more people and
lowered your case fatality rate so
as you can see you can lower cfr by
testing more people
interestingly trump's strategy has been
to test fewer people
which hurts his own strategy of focusing
on case fatality right
so that gets us to infection fatality
rate so
when you look at infection fatality
that's deaths divided by
the total believed number of infections
so remember
we're not testing everybody there are
people who have had coronavirus who
never got a test
so when we have a hundred positive tests
we have to estimate
well how many people were really
infected we might
determine that there's a 2.5 times
infection rate so for every
100 tests that go positive
you estimate you really have 250
ex believed cases so the infection
fatality rate
with one death over 250 believed
cases is only 0.4 percent
now what's important is you can lower
your infection fatality rate by
arguing that there were way more
asymptomatic people that had the virus
and recovered and are fine so
if i argue you know for every positive
test there's probably
10 people who had it i lower my
infection fatality rate dramatically
that now gets us to deaths per capita
deaths per capita are not tied to
testing or any speculation
about asymptomatic spread you're simply
dividing deaths by population
one death in a country of a hundred
people that's one percent
deaths per capita notice that death per
capita only goes up
over time assuming that you know the
population isn't growing explosively
during a pandemic
so when a second person dies in a
country of a hundred
your deaths per capita are now up to two
percent
this is important because deaths per
capita won't be impacted by
the testing level deaths per capita
won't be impacted by your estimate of
how many asymptomatic cases they are
and when you look at that the us is
currently
10th highest in the world our deaths per
million
are 432 we're right behind chile
which is at 442. so out of 200 plus
countries and territories we are 10th in
the world
if you get rid of san marino and andorra
which are tiny and
when you include countries so small it
can sometimes be deceptive
we're really eighth in the world among
reasonably sized countries
so the way that deaths per capita can be
affected
is that there could be coronavirus
deaths that aren't being counted as
coronavirus deaths
so you have to look at excess deaths
compared to last year
if you do that it seems as though we are
probably
under counting the number of coronavirus
deaths
so now you know when trump says we have
the lowest death rate
he's probably referring to the case
fatality rate even though he's also
wrong that ours is low but really we
should focus on deaths per capita
over time if you want to compare how
countries are doing
you want to look at deaths per capita if
you want to look at how
deadly the disease is among people who
get it
you would look at cfr and ifr but for
for trump's purpose which is compare how
we're doing to other countries
deaths per capita is the metric that we
should be looking at
and of course it's never the metric that
trump
or kaylee mckenna or any of them are
actually talking about
hopefully this is useful and we'll have
some of the example data
on the show's instagram page follow us
on instagram
at david patnick the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show so
during that absolutely
stunning interview with fox news's chris
wallace which we looked at earlier chris
wallace mentions a fox news poll where
biden is ahead of trump
49-41 and the poll actually has a ton of
fascinating data points now as a
reminder
fox news polling and fox news channel
are two different things fox news
polling is actually considered
um quite good and uh and accurate so a
few things as we get into it
this is a poll of registered voters
remember that
the least accurate in terms of
predicting an election is to just
survey all adults more accurate
is registered voters and then ideal is
likely voters although you tend to see
fewer likely voter polls this early you
see more of those as we get
closer to election day now one other
thing just a short circuit those claims
about oh they only called land lines we
can't trust this
as you can see in the methodology this
was done
with a 237 landline recipients
and 867 cell phones so they call cell
phones
this was mostly cell phones now on key
issues
super important on the economy
47 to 47 biden and trump
on who is better to handle the economy
the economy has been trump's one issue
lately where he was polling better than
joe biden last week in the quinnipiac
poll joe biden pulled better than trump
on the economy
in this fox news poll they are tied
that's not good for trump
not surprisingly on race relations trump
is way under water
uh only 35 approved 35 percent approve
of trump on race relations
56 percent disapprove i already
mentioned
um biden up 49 to 41 by eight
in the general election poll right now
four percent
say they would vote for other five
percent say
they don't know yet and then now it gets
really interesting when
vote when a poll recip uh poll uh poll
what would we call them poll takers uh
subjects were asked about vote by mail
63 of the country says they favor vote
by mail
compared to 28 percent who oppose this
suggests
that trump loudly opposing vote by mail
as he has been doing
may not really be a good strategy to
bring more people over to his side
now this is really important and very
interesting i recently said
if they have debates biden shouldn't go
at trump's insults or wacky behavior
i said there are three primary issues
that have hurt trump and that should be
the focus
coronavirus the economy as a result of
coronavirus
and the protest george floyd race issues
when asked what are the most important
issues today
the issues are 29 say coronavirus
15 say the economy jobs and unemployment
and 10 say race relations and police
issues so
those three issues are the top issues
for
54 of the country it's really important
to confirm our hypotheses it appeared
that
coronavirus the economy and race
relations were the most important issues
and the ones that had hurt trump the
most
and indeed it appears that that is the
case now last thing
there was a question about mental
soundness for years we've been seeing
concerning signs from trump about his
cognitive state
there's also a joe biden has dementia
movement i've admitted biden has
definitely slowed down
from where he was in his 60s despite it
not appearing to be dementia according
to every mental health expert i've
spoken to
the poll asked do you think biden and
trump have the mental soundness to serve
effectively as president 47 believe
biden has the mental soundness
only 43 percent believe trump does now
those numbers are just really low the
fact that
neither can that has half the country
believing they are mentally sound
is a problem but note that 14 percent
aren't sure about biden 7 aren't sure
about trump
the important takeaway is more people
question
trump's fitness for office than bidens
although not by a huge margin so the big
takeaways here
are our instinct about what matters this
election
has been right the polls are
consistently showing similar results
and we all have to assume nothing
and vote like our state depends on our
vote
to choose between trump and biden that's
how we should imagine
we are going to uh act on
on november 3rd or before if you're
voting early and i hope many of you do
my vote could swing my state from trump
to biden
i'm sure as hell voting in that case
let's take a quick break make sure
you're following me on instagram
at david.pacman we will be right back
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as
one dollar per month or as much as you
want
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
great perks and benefits as well read
about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so i have multiple stories today about
slurs and epithets it wasn't just donald
trump
accused of it and we will look at that
shortly it was also
donald trump's friend roger stone doing
it
on live radio calling a black man negro
during an interview remember that just
days ago donald trump commuted the
prison sentence of roger stone
and it was another one of these powerful
and defiant shows of cronyism and
corruption from donald trump
and incredibly just days after having
his sentence commuted by donald trump uh
roger stone calls into the mr mo kelly
show on los
angeles radio station kfi 6 40 am
and they're debating stone's conviction
and
at one point stone goes quiet and then
you hear him say
i don't really feel like arguing with
this negro check it out
the line then goes dead but it's really
not dead
roger stone is just sitting there not
saying anything and then he eventually
comes back and says no i didn't i didn't
say i didn't call you a negro take a
listen to this
i don't know i'd love to see standards
here that's my argument no no
i do believe that certain people are
treated differently
in the federal justice system i do
absolutely believe that
but i also believe that your friendship
and relationship in history with donald
trump
weighed more heavily than him just
wanted to make sure that justice was
done
by a person in the justice system that
you were treated so
unfairly there are thousands of people
treated unfairly daily
how your number just happened to come up
in the lottery i'm guessing it was more
than just
luck roger right
i don't really feel like arguing
i'm sorry what was that
roger
roger
i'm sorry what did you say
i'm sorry you you're arguing with him
i thought we were having just a very
spirited conversation what happened
would you not like to continue the
conversation sir
i hear that the line is not dead
uh you're back i don't know what's that
well there yeah i was i was talking and
you said something about negro so i
wasn't exactly sure
i did not oh okay you're out of your
mind uh i don't hear your mind
okay well we'll let the listeners decide
let me go to the next question then
why whatever and roger stone just
sticking with that explanation just
insisting he never said it stone again
denied making the comment in a statement
given to the christian broadcasting
network
yeah it's as funny as it sounds claiming
that there was
crosstalk and it made it difficult to
know who said what which of course
is not the case it is perfectly silent
at the time that he says it and you hear
the phrase very very clearly
and the word negro even more clearly
take a look i don't really feel like
arguing
i'm sorry what was that there must have
been uh gremlins in the phone line or a
hacker
or someone who right when roger stone
went quiet
was able to intercept the phone call and
insert the word negro
into the communication right would that
maybe be a more believable explanation
and when i listen back to it the most
obvious part about it for me is
if the phone really broke up and roger
stone couldn't hear anything for a while
and hadn't called the host a negro he
would have been really confused and
flummoxed and
outraged by the accusation that he said
negro he just immediately denies saying
it like
if i was being interviewed and for 30
seconds i couldn't hear anything
and then when i can hear the host again
the coast says
you just said something about a negro i
would say what what on earth are you
talking about i've said
nothing for 30 seconds i've never called
the black person a negro and i have no
clue what you're talking about
stone's reaction is to say no i didn't i
didn't call you a negro
it's almost orwellian like you can't
trust what you hear
and then you know pretending the line
was seemingly dead when it wasn't
there's just not that much more to say
here this is exactly the type of people
that trump has around him
it's a pretty simple analysis not
everybody who supports trump is racist
obviously but the racists overwhelmingly
support
trump and he has many of them around him
and that's sort of it you know i i don't
want to be
arguing with a negro that it's their
plane as day
this is clearly how roger stone grew up
referring to black people sometimes
people are just racist you know
there are times for more precision are
we is this an instance of prejudice or
are we talking about systemic versus
personal racism or is someone
insensitive or whatever this is just a
racist guy
who says racist things and he got caught
and that's it it's very much in line
with the trump administration technique
of sometimes they do something crazy
and then they just deny that it happened
trump said 15 cases would go to zero
uh well you know fouchy at one point
said don't wear a mask then that's
okay then they just move on and they go
to the next thing this is the guy
that roger stone commuted uh the
sentence for
just a few days ago and immediately out
there
arguing with radio hosts and referring
to them as negroes
that's what it is now we'll go from
stone to trump
now i don't want to spend a ton of time
on this
but it is newsworthy in a sense so i
want to take a look at it with you
i told you previously about donald
trump's niece mary trump
who wrote a book with a ton of
outrageous but not altogether surprising
claims about trump
he has a learning disability he paid
someone to take his sats
he was abused by his dad he was taught
never to apologize
because his dad never apologized and
they were all
believable but also not ground shaking
claims in the sense that
they don't really change our picture of
who donald trump is
well mary trump's book is out and it
sold just a crazy number of copies on
day one
it was close to a million copies sold
and mary trump was interviewed by rachel
maddow on msnbc
and mary trump says she personally heard
donald trump use the n word referring to
black people
and also anti-semitic slurs let's take a
look
i have to press you on it a little bit
um if just to ask
if the president um if your uncle was an
exception to that in your family
or if he if you if if you heard you ever
heard him express
uh either use anti-semitic slurs or the
n-word or other racist slurs or other
sentiments like that was
was it is do you mean this is an ambient
thing in your family but you can't say
that you ever heard it from him or did
you hear it from him too
oh yeah yeah of course i did um and i
i don't think that should surprise
anybody given how virulently racist he
is today
um have you heard have you heard the
president use the n-word
and anti-semitic slurs specifically
yes so this is one of those that it's so
obvious and yet so irrelevant
and yet so seemingly confusing in some
minor ways which i'm going to explain
so one of the reactions from the right
and i looked at some conservative
blogs and subreddits this morning to see
their reaction to this
a lot of people on the right have said
trump's not anti-semitic he's super
pro-israel and his daughter converted to
judaism because she married
married jared kushner who's jewish et
cetera it's a terrible argument because
first of all
trump is pro-israel from a reactionary
netanyahu sort of standpoint which is
not even the predominant view among jews
there
nor here in the united states so trump
really has done nothing
about jews being increasingly the
victims of hate crimes during his
presidency
he moved the u.s embassy from tel aviv
to jerusalem right so understand that
trump has been pro-likud but trump has
not been pro-jewish
and that's an important distinction to
make
number two is this is just not
surprising right from
everything we know about trump who can
oh my god it's shocking trump uses the
n-word in private
trump uses anti-semitic of course he
does of course he does that's not at all
surprising
but then the most important takeaway for
me is
as sick as this is it's so irrelevant
in the sense that trump is so orders of
magnitude unqualified to do this job
trump has so bungled everything that he
deserves to be removed in november
period and this barely changes anything
about it like okay you know i get it
insofar as trump using the n word
personally hasn't gotten very much
attention
trump using anti-semitic slurs
personally it's not getting that much
attention i get it
you know when mary trump said this on
the rachel maddow show it got
24 hours of attention and then it faded
there's two reasons for that
the coronavirus pandemic continues to
rage and grow
it's not surprising that trump is
accused of saying this
but most importantly it's not materially
materially relevant to voting trump out
it changes nothing if you still support
trump at this point
you're probably not bailing because he's
accused of using the n word about black
people
and using anti-semitic slurs about jews
you're just sticking with them if you're
still with them at this point
if you're already not supporting donald
trump
you're still not going to support him
after hearing him accused of using the
n-word
and anti-semitic slurs in other words it
is additional data
that provides almost no additional
information
about who we should vote for because
it's what we believed he was doing
all along that's my two cents on it let
me know if you disagree or have
something to add
we probably won't spend much additional
time on it
we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david
p uh we have heard a number of times
recently from this furious trumpist who
calls in jimmy from philly
the eggman a long time caller and viewer
and listener
who we love we love the eggman he called
in and he is now going directly at
jimmy from philly take a listen to this
hey dave
this is a message for your employee uh
jimmy from philly
that's a joke by the way jimmy is just a
caller i wanted to tell him
why we take our children to blm rallies
we take them because we don't want our
children to grow up to be
racist homophobic [ __ ]
like you right shalom a huge shalom a
huge
huge shot across the bow there from the
eggman against jimmy from philly
um and we will see if i get 10
voicemails from jimmy
responding to the eggman four of which
will have a bad reception
six of which will be way too loud to use
we'll see if that happens uh when i wake
up tomorrow morning
on the bonus show today we are in the
last week
almost in the last week last full week i
guess maybe we could say
of that enhanced 600 unemployment
benefit
related to coronavirus that's going to
have a big impact when it ends and we're
going to talk about it on today's bonus
show
we also were seeing police use drones
even to monitor nudity at a minnesota
beach
and i want to talk about that and
there's the context of
facial recognition technology and other
things that are relevant
and number three uh not the best health
news
for supreme court justice ruth bader
ginsburg we're going to talk about
what's going on
this is putting a renewed focus on the
supreme court
and what may or may not uh be
supreme court picks that that trump
would have in the remainder
of this term or in a possible second
term and how mitch mcconnell might try
to obstruct and and
we're gonna see how it all plays out but
we will have a
serious discussion about it on the bonus
show today make sure you get access to
the bonus show by becoming a member at
joinpackman.com
also something extra tonight 9 p.m
eastern
i will be doing a live stream on twitch
with international chess master eric
rosen
a friend of the show my continued
training for a big
upcoming tournament where i am looking
to represent the progressive political
community very powerfully in a chess
tournament
um i am taking i actually am taking it
seriously join my training tonight on
twitch at 9 pm eastern
twitch.tv david pakman
it's all happening and remember if you
prefer
a one hour long form audio podcast
each day rather than little cut up clips
on youtube
you can get our daily audio podcast for
free
on any of your favorite podcasting
platforms a lot of people use itunes
many people prefer spotify we're on
pandora
google play stitcher all of the
pod bean uh what else spreaker i don't
even know all the platforms we're on
but you can consume the show daily in
that way and as people
hopefully in like nine months get back
to safely commuting to work
um you'll be able to take a show with
you in that format remember the audio
podcast available daily
i will speak to you in mere moments on
today's bonus show
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 off of a subscription when
you go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've also included the link
right underneath this video